the following trailer is what it s for
spoilers but come on people seriously
[Music]
after his breakout hit but before we had
to break up with him oh and that
Shyamalan was still unbreakable you like
split and after someone explained why
Bruce Willis was in it you keep meaning
to check out unbreakable the atmospheric
thinking man's comic book film that M
night kept insisting would be a trilogy
then that kept not happening which in
hindsight was a really good thing
because he had a lot of crap to get out
of the system first plan on murdering me
in my sleep what no worth it Bruce
Willis shines as David done a detached
middle-aged man who doesn't take full
advantage of his talents and just kind
of mopes around even though he's got it
all
aka Bruce Willis oh yeah watch as his
dreary life is turned upside down by
Elijah price a fragile obsessive who
insists that everyone likes comics the
same way that he does this is an art
gallery my friend and this is a piece of
art and who's prone to angry violent
outbursts aka modern-day comics fans
together they'll shake up David's
midlife crisis by discovering he has the
power to lift any weight lick any toilet
seat and pause for any amount of time in
the middle of a sentence I'm so moving
there
God just not now sometimes
just not right this morning what's the
first morning that I can remember that I
didn't open my eyes we feel sadness
strapped in for everything you love
about early Shyamalan like clunky
dialogue
you can't let bad things happen to good
people right that's your code right
that's the heroes code something about
water being scary afraid of water you
have a weakness water do you remember
the story about them about the boy that
almost drowned in the pool and a twist
you'll never see coming the first time
that will be so obvious the second time
around you won't know how you missed it
they say this one has a surprise ending
I mean is it still a twist if you're
expecting a twist or is the real twist
knowing he knows you think the twist is
coming so he probably won't do a twist
then doing it to us anyway boom
Shyamalan
so before you experience the
mind-blowing scale the next big comic
book movie dial things back like way
back for a superhero film that does it
all without CGI epic battles or sky
beings because sometimes all it takes to
tell an epic story is the power of
stairs
[Music]
Sturridge sigh hard Haley Joel Osment
brick man and Robin and in West
Philadelphia born and raised near the
playground was how he spent most of his
days healing ups taxing cos beta so
cruel too sick to shoot bball outside of
his school then an unbreakable guy it
was up to some good started saving
children in the neighborhood he derailed
one little train and the guy got scared
and said I'm sending to an asylum for
psychological care man of feels
you better not be jacking off to the
Japanese comics I swear to God it is
called hentai and it is art good day sir
chickens float in secret supremacy
pumpernickel roses are red my name is
Dave this makes no sense
microwave the baboon's have my tonsils
I just watched venom for the eddying
venom romance